what's the last thing anyone expected to
see in the first episode of she-hulk how
about busted tech from mcu phase two
here's the history behind the surprising
memento the marvel cinematic universe
has thrilled audiences on the big and
small screen for more than a decade and
in all that time there's only been one
in-universe version of the hulk bruce
banner was originally played by edward
norton in the incredible hulk before
mark ruffalo came aboard for the
avengers but it's the same character in
the mcu however the hero has been joined
by a brand new jade giant jennifer
walters also known as she-hulk played by
tatiana maslany of orphan black fame jen
gets her powers from bruce's blood when
they get into a car accident due to a
sicarian ship showing up out of nowhere
a seeming nod to the world war hulk
comics the series kicks things off by
establishing a fun dynamic between the
two cousins as professor hulk tries to
teach jen everything there is to know
about being a hulk speaking to access
hollywood in february ruffalo had high
praise for maslany freaking legendary as
a she-hulk um i'm passing the banner
onto her ruffalo added there are some
really good funny cool long long scenes
between professor and her we've never
really seen the hulk interact with
people the way he does in that show
it'll be really interesting bruce and
jen spend plenty of time in the isolated
mexican laboratory where the scientist
learned to merge his two selves in the
time between avengers infinity war and
avengers end game but when walters is
wandering around the building she finds
a bittersweet iron man memento that has
us all in our feelings here's why it's
so familiar although she-hulk is
obviously about jennifer walters and how
she balances her legal career alongside
her burgeoning responsibilities as a
superhero the show also takes the
opportunity to look at bruce banner a
little more closely episode one reveals
that bruce spent a lot of time with tony
stark in the five-year blip gap after
avengers infinity war because the
billionaire playboy philanthropist
funded his laboratory they even built a
beachside bar together to have some fun
even in a dramatic time but bruce seems
to have done more of the work than his
pal
tony mostly drank just sat around
complaining about steve when jen is
wandering through the house she finds a
ruined iron man helmet that bruce is
clearly keeping to remember his fallen
friend it seems like the black and gold
helmet could be from a mark 20 python
suit which briefly shows up with several
other suits at the end of iron man 3.
fans will remember that bruce briefly
appears in the post-credits scene of the
2013 movie nodding off while listening
to tony ramble on but the mark 20 suit
blows up on tony's orders after the
final big battle in iron man 3. so it's
way more likely that the memento is
actually an iron legion droid head from
the avengers age of ultron era these
unwearable suits were ultimately used
against the avengers when ultron who was
developed with bruce's help took control
of them this little memento reminds us
that tony and bruce had a real
friendship that thrived outside of
saving the world when the two first meet
in the avengers tony tells bruce that
he's a big fan of his especially when he
grows into an enormous green rage
monster over the years we see them
connect and grow as friends working on
projects and driving around in supercars
together using a small part of she-hulk
attorney at law to look a little closer
at hulk's character arc is a clever move
from marvel after all the giant hero
hasn't had his own solo movie since 2008
since the distribution rights for the
character are universal so any mcu hulk
action is a welcome turn of events even
on the small screen
[Music]